immortal being daughter of elrond wife
of aragorn
and queen of gondor arwen the elf lived
quite a long and adventurous life
even before frodo and friends stumbled
into her neck of the woods in fellowship
of the ring
here's arwen's entire backstory
explained
ancestry is often a key part of what
defines a person's path in life
and with arwyn it's essential right from
birth
her lineage both in the recent and
distant past makes her a prime candidate
for the middle earth limelight
let's start with the familiar faces
first arwen's dad is elrond
as the leader of rivendell a venerable
warrior and a famous counselor
arwen's father is practically always at
the center of the continent's politics
and wars
and his daughter is often by his side in
rivendale observing the action
and then there's arwen's maternal
grandmother galadriel
the lady of the golden wood is about as
old as an elf can get
and she's witnessed nearly all of middle
earth's long traumatic history
she has incredible power wields an elven
ring and is one of sauron's chief
enemies
while having elrond and galadriel as her
family members is
already enough to set our win up as a
pretty important shielf
the hereditary connections don't stop
there arwin's family history is studded
with famous people
particularly through her father elrond's
father is aaron deal the mariner the
half-elf half-man hero that saves the
good guys from destruction at the end of
the first age of middle-earth history
on top of that elrond's mother is elwing
the granddaughter of the man baron and
the half-elven half-angelic luthien
the power couple and one of tolkien's
most famous first age epics
and the thing is we're only touching on
the most famous of her relatives here
there are several others who play
critical roles in tolkien's other
writings
especially the silmarillion suffice it
to say arwen is the middle-earth
equivalent of the offspring of a
marriage between a rock star and a
hollywood celebrity
for those of you who didn't notice she's
also descended from men
elves and the angelic mayar giving her
and her immediate family a unique
connection to all three races
according to the appendix of the return
of the king arwen is born 241 years into
the third age
that makes her approximately 2778 years
old by the time the one ring is
destroyed
which isn't terribly old for an elf in
comparison
galadriel is over 8 000 however it does
give her a good step up on her future
husband's 88-year lifespan
when arwen is born the world is
relatively peaceful a few hundred years
away from the epic war of the last
alliance
that's the event depicted in the opening
sequence of the fellowship of the ring
where men elves and dwarves join
together to resist sauron's first run at
conquering the continent
when the dust settles the dark lord is
defeated the ring has been cut from his
hand
and middle-earth settles down for a long
period of relative peace and prosperity
the primary thing to point out during
these early centuries of armin's life is
the fact that while the power of men
grows in middle earth
the elves and dwarves slowly begin to
fade into obscurity
and that's not to say that they're
inconsequential places like lothlorien
rivendell and khazad doom are still
powerful and influential
however they stop trending up at this
point in time and if anything
begin to lose the larger political and
military power that they once had
her people may have been slowly fading
but the first few thousand years of
arwen's life are ones of peaceful
comfort
she spends a lot of her time bouncing
between rivendell and lothlorian with
her grandparents
in the return of the king she even
casually mentions that she'd been in
lothlorian for a while
while there aren't a ton of details on
arwen's early activity the bulk of her
time for the greater part of 3000 years
seems to have been spent following this
pattern of living in one of the two
elven havens
or traveling between them in addition to
her famous father and grandmother arwen
also has two older twin brothers
ella dan and elro here as well as a
mother named calebrion
however over time she sees each of these
familial connections less often
primarily due to a tragic event that
happens to her mother about 500 years
before the war of the ring
tragedy strikes the family when their
mother is captured by orcs in the misty
mountains
she's eventually found and rescued by
her sons but by then
she's been tortured and poisoned a
devastated elrond manages to save her
life showing a glimpse of the skill that
he later uses to save frodo from his
deadly knife wound
however calebrion is so traumatized by
the experience that she never fully
recovers her former health
and eventually decides to leave
middle-earth to seek peace and healing
in the blessed
realm the same place that frodo sails to
at the end of the return of the king
after this experience arwen's brothers
become especially bitter towards the
orcs
and spend much of their time out hunting
their foes often teaming up with the
rangers in the process
eventually this morbid hobby even leads
to their being present when aragorn's
father is killed by orcs making his
young son chieftain in the process
and that serves as the perfect segue to
finally introduce arwin's bow
soon after one of arwin's trips back
from rivendale she decides to take a
walk and who should appear on the path
in front of her but a young man
tell everyone who the young man is
legolas this is no mere ranger
he is aragorn
at this point he's a 20 year old
stripling who's over the moon because he
just found out that he's the chieftain
of the dunadine and the heir to the
throne of gondor
when the two meet it's love at first
sight at least for aragorn
arwen is little more than amused by his
head over heels attraction to her beauty
nevertheless aragorn sets his heart on
pursuing the elvish maiden which quickly
leads to a gentle but stern
confrontation with elrod
the loremaster sadly prophesies to the
young ranger that arwin will only marry
him if he becomes king
and that in either case either she or
aragorn will eventually be heartbroken
by the situation
if sauron is defeated and aragorn made
king and all that you hope for comes
true you will still have to taste the
bitterness of mortality
the budding relationship between arwen
and aragorn brings up an interesting
question
are the two related the short answer is
well yes
in fact in return of the king when we
learn how they met and aragorn explains
who he is
arwen's immediate response is that we
are kin from afar
however while their bloodlines are
related it's definitely a very
very distant connection elrond's brother
is a man
and we mean literally a man named elros
with their unique family history the
brothers and their descendants are
allowed to choose between either an
immortal or a mortal life
while elrond chooses immortality his
brother opts for mortality
and ends up leading a nation of men
called numenor over time
that nation becomes one of sauron's
chief enemies and eventually
it's the numenoreans who set up the two
kingdoms of arnor and gondor
when arnor collapses its royal bloodline
secretly survives through the rangers
and their line of chieftains
the last of whom is aragorn in other
words
there are dozens of generations between
irwin and aragorn making them
technically but extremely distantly
related
considering the fact that tolkien came
from a world where english royalty
was constantly intermarrying with first
and second cousins
the magnitude of the distance in aragorn
and irwin's relationship would hardly
have seemed to be much of a concern
over time aragorn makes his case darwin
in a convincing yet
indirect way when he discovers that he
doesn't have a shot with elrond's
daughter at present the ranger leaves
rivendell and heads out into the wide
world to forge his own path
in the ensuing decades the exiled king
proves himself over and over again
he travels in the wild fights in
disguise in rohan and gondor
befriends gandalf and even makes a solo
trip far into the mysterious eastern and
southern regions of the continent
over this time the son of aerothorn
evolves from an inexperienced
young man to a battle-hardened warrior
he gains wisdom and experience beyond
his years
[Music]
years that quickly add up while still a
drop in the bucket
the next time he meets arwen aragorn is
around 50 years old
this time they hook up in lothlorien and
it's arwin who's surprised to see
aragorn walking towards her through the
trees
they spend a season together and darwin
officially falls in love with the now
mature
exiled king by the time they part ways
they've committed to marrying each other
and elrond gives his sad approval
though he clarifies that his daughter
will marry no one less than the king of
arnor and gondor
after she's officially betrothed to
aragorn arwen spends most of the next
few decades in rivendale as things ramp
up to the war of the ring
once the war breaks out her role varies
depending on if you're reading the books
or watching the movies
arwen remains more or less on the
sidelines throughout the book series
however just because she's out of sight
doesn't mean she's out of mind
in fact aragorn is depicted thinking of
her on multiple occasions
for instance when the fellowship arrives
in la florian frodo sees the ranger
wrapped in a memory in the same place
where he and arwen got engaged
in addition to remembrances arwen meets
with aragorn when he arrives with the
hobbits in rivendell
she also personally makes an enormous
banner that aragorn unveils during the
battle of pelinor fields
using it to officially announce his
return as the king
arwen's role was dramatically beefed up
for peter jackson's trilogy
the shielf helps frodo escape from the
black riders revives a waterlogged
aragorn via a vision
and is repeatedly shown struggling with
her father's desire for her to leave
middle-earth
rather than become mortal even in this
enhanced role though
harwin's participation in the plot is
actually reduced from the original
cinematic scripts
in an interview with ign liv tyler
herself clarified that the character was
supposed to be much more heavily
involved in the story
in an earlier version of the script she
was actually supposed to lead the elf
contingent that fights it helms deep in
the two towers
however as they shot the movie the
filmmakers realized that inserting arwen
into the violent action
wasn't doing justice to her character
tyler herself points out that
you don't have to put a sword in a
woman's hand to make her seem tough
that's little actual makeup of who arwin
is and her sheer will and strength and
love for this man was strong enough
whether she had been depicted in battle
or not though there's no doubt that
arwen is more present in the film
adaptations than she ever is in the
original the lord of the rings story
both the written and cinematic versions
of arwin's story reconnect when she
marries aragorn
in all of the annals of middle-earth
lore this becomes just the third time
that an elf and a man get hitched
with both of the previous unions also
taking place in their shared family tree
their nuptials are a high water mark in
the story of the two lovers
of course arwen's marriage also means
she officially becomes the queen of the
reunited realms of gondor and arnor
practically overnight this makes her the
most powerful woman in all of middle
earth
as queen she helps aragorn rule their
kingdom for 120 years
during that time she brings sam's
daughter eleanor to be her maid of honor
in minas tirith
she also has at least two daughters who
remain nameless
and a son named eldarian who eventually
succeeds his father to the throne
one of the most complicated and
confusing elements about arwen's life
is her mortality or more accurately her
immortality that is replaced by
mortality
in essence arwen is allowed to choose
between being immortal or mortal
since she has both elves and men in her
ancestry the life of the elders leaving
you
this was my choice however
the specific ground rules for this
choice are never clarified by tolkien
it would appear that at least once
someone chooses to be mortal
the choice isn't given to their children
regardless of the specifics
arwin lives as an immortal elf until she
gives up her immortality to marry
aragorn
i choose a mortal life
this enables her to grant frodo her spot
on the ship headed west to the blessed
realm
but it also sets her up for a painfully
difficult parting as well
when arwyn discusses her choice to
become mortal in the return of the king
she explains that she is chosen quote
both the sweet and the bitter
and 120 years after her marriage to
aragorn the bitter part really comes
home to roost
after he passes and aldarian becomes
king it says in the book that in her
sorrow
she says goodbye to her children and her
loved ones and then she leaves minas
tirith returning to her past home of
lothlorien
however by this time galadriel and her
people have left
and no elves remain in the golden wood
she wanders there through the following
winter and then finally lies down to
rest in the same place where she had
betrothed herself to aragorn so many
years before
there tasting the bitterness at the very
end of her mortal life she passes away
quietly
eventually surrounded by a green grave
that will never change until the world
itself is altered
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite fantasy characters are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one